[Musik]
sebastian lege zeigt euch heute wie die
industrie mit einem trick weizenbrötchen
wie vollkorn aussehen lässt
von einem handwerksbäcker erfährt er was
in ein echtes vollkornbrötchen gehört
wie man das ganz leicht im supermarkt
erkennen kann
[Musik]
in düsseldorf ist becker johannes
bergweiler stolz auf seine
vollkornbrötchen sebastian läge aber hat
alles dabei für schimmel brötchen aller
industrie
[Musik]
für dunkle brötchen braucht die
industrie kein teures volk und wie man
bei leeres mitgebrachten exemplaren
sieht
naja sehen aus wie vollkornbrot erstmal
aus dem vollkommen produzieren definitiv
ja das hat mir mal deinen
vollkornbrötchen was jetzt den mann am
nächsten kommt dass er so genannten
vollkornbrötchen ja tatsächlich auch
wenn das fitness brötchen noch nicht
fertig gebacken ist optisch ähnelt es
dem bäcker brötchen
auffällig der preisunterschied das
bäcker brötchen kostet 80 cent
das der industrie nur und 32 das kostet
richtig geld an brötchen oder das
herzstück ist natürlich unsere
vollkornmehl weizen vollkommene was wir
selber in der wtcc nur formalen der
bäcker malt sein vollkornmehl noch
selbst das macht die zutat hochwertig
aber auch teurer
[Musik]
gleich mal zeigen dass man das nicht
braucht um ein brötchen zu backen was
aussieht wie vollkorn aber gar kein
vollkorn ist überzeugen muss mich nicht
[Gelächter]
sebastian fordert johannes zum duell
heraus
ran an den teig
doch nur der des bäckers besteht aus
echtem vollkorn sebastian dagegen greift
auf günstiges weizenmehl zurück das ist
preiswerter weil einfacher herzustellen
aber mit weißem mehl lassen sich nur
weiße brötchen backen
eigentlich
[Musik]
würde ich das ja zu backen würden die
leute auf der strasse denken ja
klassisches weizenbrötchen ich habe auch
noch ein bisschen farbe und wie trägt
sich da was mal auf gerste malz extrakt
20 gramm von diesem pulver verwandelt
mein herkömmliches weizenmehl optisch in
ein vollkornbrötchen und ist dadurch
natürlich auch wesentlich günstiger
gerstenmalz extrakt ist eine uralte
zutat beim bierbrauen wird aber auch für
backwaren benutzt er gibt aroma leichte
süße und farbe und auf die farbe kommt
es heute an
guck mal hier zeigt das muss ich das
noch ein bisschen durch
guck mal johannes das ist um ein
herkömmliches weizenmehl bisschen gerste
malz extrakt gefärbt sieht original
ausgedacht
ich weiß das erschrecken unterschied zu
sehen ob das auch nach dem backen so
bleibt zuerst werden die zutaten
vermengt ein bisschen mehr wie du warum
weil die vollkorn anteile mehr natürlich
jetzt auch quellen beim kneten prozessen
etwas aufnehmen können außerdem enthält
das vollkornmehl weniger weizen kleber
als industrie weiß nie
deshalb auch der teig mehr zeit beim
kneten sebastians mail ist dagegen ob
schnelle verarbeitung optimiert
auch wenn die farbe gleich ist noch gibt
es unterschiede
dann sieht man natürlich schon auch hier
hat eine ganz andere strukturen also auf
deiner fühlt sich ganz anders an der ist
viel saftiger auf weihnacht ist
wesentlich elastischer der ist er so ein
bisschen diese datei denn die mail sorte
bestimmt die teig struktur
[Musik]
jetzt hier rein sagt ich in den köpfen
der hebel betätigen
[Musik]
mit einer alten brötchen maschine
stechen produktentwickler und becker die
teiglinge aus
ach guck mal gar nicht so schlecht jetzt
müssen die teige noch aufgehen
mit zwei stunden ist sebastians
gefärbter weizenmehl type schneller ein
vorteil auch für die industrie derzeit
kostet geld
was aber unterscheidet braune billig
brötchen im kern von teurem vollkorn das
will sebastian auf exklusive weise
veranschaulichen
zur sicherheit mit feuerwehr schutz
sorgt dafür dass ich die leute hier
nicht abfackelt oder sehr schön
[Musik]
wie die sicherheit ist gesorgt wir sagen
vorher frei symbolisch will er zeigen im
mehl steckt viel energie nur setzen
vollkorn und weizenmehl diese energie
ganz unterschiedlich frei
drei esslöffel gibt er in den trichter
und dann luftpumpe marsch
[Musik]
das passiert wenn weizenmehl durch eine
flamme geblasen wird
solche mehlstaub explosionen waren
früher der horror jedes müller
[Musik]
jetzt nehmen wir mal vollkornmehl
wieder gibt lege drei esslöffel in den
trichter
[Musik]
achtung im gegensatz zum weizenmehl
passiert hier fast gar nichts
brennt dann so schnell wie weit es nicht
das liegt an den vielen ballast und
mineralstoffen die ihn vollkornmehl
stecken die verbrennen nicht so einfach
im klassischen weißmehl dagegen fehlen
sie ähnlich verbrennt auch in unserem
körper das weizenmehl die energie wird
schnell freigesetzt
vollkornmehl dagegen wird langsam
verdaut und macht länger satt
deshalb gilt es auch als gesünder in der
backstube sind beide brötchen teige fast
fertig für den ofen mit satten und
körnern bedeckt sind die schummel
schritten von den echten kaum zu
unterscheiden
selbst für profis wie den bäckermeister
johannes sag mal ehrlich jetzt so nach
dem g vorgang
ich muss jetzt wirklich auch mal das
sind deine und das sehr genau hinschauen
ich bin wirklich baff krass in rohform
gibt es kaum einen unterschied 20
minuten müssen die brötchen jetzt im
ofen backen
schauen wir uns mal an
tja
sondern mädchen spielen auch in fertig
gebacken kein unterschied erkennbar
die zuschauer können sie erkennen
welches brötchen mit ersten mals
eingefärbt wurde und welches eine wahre
handwerkskunst ist von einem bio
vollkorn becker richtig ist links liegen
die echten vollkornbrötchen rechts die
fakes dunkel eingefärbt mit miles
extrakt
doch nicht nur äußerlich ähneln sich die
brötchen auch das innere wirkt identisch
wenn das dann eben noch mit seiten
vermischt ist dann ist es nicht mehr zu
unterscheiden
und was sagt der geschmack sebastian
testet dann schmeckt ein bisschen anders
viel mehr aroma vielmehr körper es hat
allen anderen bist du bist nicht so
genau
fester und noch so ein bisschen mineral
schaffen nicht so der geschmack erst im
direkten geschmacks vergleich fallen die
unterschiede auf auch bei abgepackten
brötchen aus supermarkt und discounter
kann der optische eindruck täuschen und
aufdrucke wie vital fit oder rustikal
helfen auch nicht weiter
woran erkennt man denn nun echtes
vollkorn
als verbraucher kann ich verpacktes brot
einfach umdrehen
auf der rückseite muss die bezeichnung
stehen und schon die bezeichnung muss
stimmen
wenn dort vollkorn steht in der
bezeichnung dann ist es auch ein
vollkornbrot
und das gilt auch bei brötchen wenn auf
der verpackung ausdrücklich von vollkorn
die rede ist muss auch zu mehr als 50%
vollkornmehl drin stecken die teig farbe
oder körner obendrauf sagen dagegen
nichts über die verwendete mail sorte
auf
[Musik]
was kommt bei euch auf den
frühstückstisch weizen dinkel oder doch
lieber vollkornbrötchen sagt es uns in
den kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser oder schaut in die nächsten zwei
clips